an extended Disney Princess scene cameos
by kylo Ren and the Golden Girls plus
more fix-it Felix and Calhoun are just
some of the many scenes cut from Ralph
breaks the Internet
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm revealing everything that
was deleted from the wreck it Ralph
sequel including some incredible cameos
and jokes you may wish have been in the
movie
keep watching to the end to find out the
amazing extended Stanley scene that
didn't make it into the final film my
Funko pops giveaway is also running on
this video so hit the bell and tap the
gleam link in the video description to
enter mild spoilers ahead dive captain
to a minimum and there are no spoilers
for the ending the Disney Princess
team-up in Ralph's break the Internet is
one of the movie's highlights however
originally the scene played out rather
differently in early versions of the
story
vanellope Ralph and yes were all at oh
my Disney together and saw the
princesses greeting fans there yes gave
vanellope a tour of the Disney fan site
and stormtroopers escorted the
princesses backstage were Penelope
followed them footage shown at Disney's
d23 Expo in 2017 also revealed several
extra jokes that were cut from the final
film
for example jasmine was allergic to cats
and her pet tiger Raja looked at her
slightly offended as she puffed on an
inhaler and Snow White always look
surprised because she was secretly
legally blind and needed a pair of thick
glasses
c-3po also originally had an extended
scene with the princesses after he
arrived in the green room to tell them
there was another which Disney Princess
a you quiz about to start in the deleted
footage Cinderella replied why Thank You
r2d2 and the other princesses joined in
poking fun at him Sleeping Beauty told
Cinderella that the Star Wars droid
hates being called that but then trolled
him with the line we'll be right there
bb-8 c-3po feigning mortally offended
walked out mumbling such insolence
you're good with princesses they said
you'll love this job oh how I long for
the days of Captain solo these extended
jokes were probably deleted to create
better comedy timing in the scene and
better pacing in the movie overall but I
wonder whether the c-3po jokes ended up
being trimmed because some Star Wars
fans were disappointed that their iconic
Princess Leia didn't appear in the sea
the wreck-it Ralph two filmmakers
decided to only use so-called canonized
Disney Princesses from the official
Disney line for the scene excluding
various other princesses from Disney
animated movies and Disney owned
properties like Star Wars they did
however add Elsa Anna and Moana who
aren't past the official princess lineup
but they are hugely popular and it's
rumored they'll be joining the official
list soon by the way vanellope taking
selfies with the princesses doesn't
appear in the movie either so it's
unclear if that's part of a scene cut
from the film or a moment just created
for marketing just before vanellope and
the Disney Princesses meet there was
going to be another extended Star Wars
crossover scene after the hoodie
princess gets accused of peddling
unauthorized click beta oh my Disney she
escapes from the stormtroopers and in an
extended version of this scene vanellope
jumped onto Dumbo and flew off with a
little elephant while getting chased by
Tie Fighters in the final movie the Star
Wars chases stripped right back and
shows vanellope fleeing on foot from the
stormtroopers before cutting straight to
her glitching into the princess room
backstage another scene we never saw
involved a joke at the expense of Star
Wars baddie kylo Ren Lucasfilm objected
to how he was going to be portrayed in
the animated movie co-director rich
Moore explained there was a joke about
kylo Ren being kind of a spoiled child
but after they took it to Lucasfilm to
show them what they were doing they said
well we prefer that you don't show him
like that you know he is our villain and
we prefer you don't do that
it seems a shame this kylo Ren cameo got
cut as the jokes in Ralph breaks the
Internet are generally gentle drives
that affectionately parody characters
from Disney's broad range of properties
and I imagine the kylo Ren joke would
have got quite a few laughs especially
as a Star Wars villain certainly has
formed when it comes to acting out like
a spoiled child it's also possible that
with the current Star Wars trilogy about
to complete in episode 9 Lucasfilm were
concerned that joke might cause some
kind of problem for were there taking
kylo Ren in their next movie a Star Wars
inspired character double Dan who has a
Jabba the Hutt style appearance also had
an additional scene deleted when Ralph
goes to the darknet with family he meets
the half-human half worm character
double Dan and the second head he has
living in
his neck what do you doing here hmm the
reason I came to your neck of the face I
mean there's a face in your neck I mean
woods neck of the woods originally there
was going to be a lady in the [ __ ]
moment here where we see the two Dan's
eating a virus together and just like
the iconic spaghetti and meatballs seen
the to Dan's end up kissing there's a
stack of Disney cameos in the movies oh
my Disney scenes but originally the four
lead characters from the popular 80s
sitcom The Golden Girls were also going
to make an appearance the idea for these
cameos came when the filmmakers were
researching the real-life oh my Disney
website and noticed the Golden Girls
featured heavily there however during
early screenings of wreck-it Ralph too
some people were confused about why
Blanche Rose Dorothy and Sophia were in
the scene and so they ended up being cut
from the film although the hit sitcom
aired on NBC it was produced by Disney
and the for actresses received Disney
Legends Awards in 2009 so it is a real
shame they didn't make it into the movie
in fact co-director Phil Johnston has
said it's one of his biggest regrets
although fan favorite Tinkerbell did
make a very brief appearance in wreck-it
Ralph - when vanellope brushed past her
backstage oh my Disney originally
Disney's best-known fairy had a larger
role in the movie in footage shown at
d23 there was a scene where Tinkerbell
tickled Ralph's nose until he insulted
her by calling her stinker smell this
might have been a fun little moment so I
imagine it was cut simply because the
film makers changed the story and Ralph
no longer accompanied vanellope on her
visit to oh my Disney fans of fix-it
Felix and Calhoun maybe a little
disappointed that the pair got a much
smaller role in the sequel although they
did get to deliver some hilarious
perfect parenting advice that none of us
will ever know the truth about but the
original story envisioned a much bigger
role for the couple as during the second
act we would have seen how the pair of
kopi were trying to bring up a horde of
unruly races the way this was initially
going to happen was that there was going
to be another character in the movie
called
Bev who was not only the head of an
antivirus company but was also a secret
villain who was tracking what Ralph was
doing on the internet which led her to
the arcade by returning to the arcade
midway through the movie we would have
got more screen time with fear
some calhoune but once the Bev antivirus
plot was dropped of course that didn't
happen it does feel a bit like the geo
story was a little abbreviated with
something missing in the middle but at
least now we know why it feels like that
the pancake milkshake game was an
instant hit when it debuted in the
film's first trailer and originally it
was supposed to appear in the main part
of the movie with Ralph and vanellope
visiting the game when they were loot
hunting oh geez
am I awake yes thank you no see I don't
understand why people like this game in
the kitty for a little while
no the kitty gets the milkshake the
bunny
[Music]
in fact this scene was one of the first
ideas to be fully animated however as a
story developed the directors felt that
Ralph and vanellope solute hunting
activities were dragging out too long
so they deleted the scene and went
straight to slaughter race instead to
move the plot forward more quickly the
problem was at that point Disney had
already started commissioning production
of Funko pops plushies and other toys
for the bunny and the cats
fortunately co-writer and director Phil
Johnston came up with the idea of
keeping the scene as a mid credit
stinger and turning it into a
deliciously meta joke funnily enough
Johnston's fellow wreck-it Ralph -
director rich Morris confessed that he's
exactly the kind of person who goes
crazy when a trailer scene doesn't show
up in the film he's watching I wonder if
he's also the kind of person who likes
watching deleted scenes videos on
YouTube by the way I reveal how Ralph
breaks the internet trolls all us Disney
Marvel and Pixar fans in my other video
which I'll add links to at the end and
in the video description while
developing the first wreck-it Ralph
movie Disney managed to secure the
rights to include Mario and Luigi from
the super mario games in the end though
the filmmakers couldn't find a good way
to include the famous video game
characters in the movie however rich
Moore did state that he wanted Mario to
appear in the sequel sadly though by the
time the sequel entered development the
rights were no longer available to
Disney meaning everyone's favorite
Italian plumber couldn't
here in Ralph's breaks the Internet
Marvel Comics legend Stan Lee passed
away shortly before the release of the
wreck-it ralph sequel making his brief
appearance in the film a particularly
poignant moment for Marvel fans and it's
especially sad that originally a much
longer extended scene was planned for
the comic book superstar an earlier
version of Lee's cameo featured a device
called the Marvel Iser where avatars for
net users would transform into a Marvel
character after walking through a
machine that looked similar to a metal
detector Stanley would have also walked
through the machine but unfortunately
when the scene ended up on the cutting
room floor we never got to see just
which Marvel character Disney thought
Stanley was Marvel fans will know
there's a theory that Stanley's cameos
in the MCU mean he's a character known
as who uatu the watcher and I wonder
whether we might have seen that theory
confirmed now do you wish any of these
deleted scenes and cameos were in the
final film let me know in the comments
below and remember to subscribe and
click on the gleam link in the video
description for a chance to win an
awesome wreck-it Ralph Funko pop
Congrats to the winners of my grinch
giveaway send me an email with your
details so I can get your prize are sent
out to you tapleft to check out every
secret easter egg you missed in the
Disney Princess scene or tap right for
another video you're sure to LIKE and if
you enjoyed this remember to share and
leave a thumbs up for more videos like
this thanks for watching and see you
next time you pick a movie lovers